in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Joann
is with us hi Joanne how are you I'm
really good how are you I am better than
I deserve
so I see on my screen that you're here
to do your debt free scream so who's
this with you this is my boyfriend John
ah here for moral support
yes very good I'm all the way from the
Chicagoland area
yeah he looks drag oh very cool well
welcome how much have you paid off
altogether forty-nine thousand four
hundred thirty nine dollars and seventy
cents dangerously close to 50k yes I
love it and how long did it take you to
pay off fifty thousand dollars fifteen
months whoa yeah and your income is I'm
in the 70s so I'm in sales so it varies
but we'll just say I'm in the seventy
rate okay what do you sell office
furniture so I I do space planning
material selections we deliver and
install the furniture so yeah same ax
furniture nerd yeah you know very cool
good well Chicago certainly a big market
for all that so what a great place to do
that so what kind of debt was the fifty
thousand so I had a little car debt it
was about twenty three hundred and then
the rest was all lovely student loans
had to kick Sallie Mae out yes had to
give the old woman her eviction notice
yep okay very good so how old are you I
am 31 years old very good and you paid
off $50,000 in fifteen months making
seventy K that's very impressive very
very well done so what did you do what
happened 15 months ago that made you
decide to do this all of a sudden um
well we kind of started getting a little
bit more serious aren't in our
relationship and you start to talk about
those things that you don't talk about
on your first date yeah watch places how
screwed up my money is yeah okay yeah
and it was it's crazy because he doesn't
have any student debt and he never did
he his parents were fortunate enough to
pay for his student loans and my parents
both born in Poland mm-hmm you know I
I'm lucky that I got to go to college
and so
the only way that I code was by getting
student loans and yeah so we talked
about it and then I realized it's not
really all that fair to make him have to
pay that off if we you know go in that
direction with our relationship so I I
decided that I need to definitely um you
know step my game up if I okay he was
eight he's more than drug here he's been
your true leader
he's been cheering you on yeah very cool
good very good excellent well that's
cool
so you got after it then yeah I mean you
turned on the fire
fifty thousand bucks in fifteen months I
mean did you sell stuff no I I had a
pretty decent emergency fund at that I
threw at it come on I think it was maybe
only about seven or eight so you know
having a condo you kind of wanted to
know a little bit of that but I dropped
it down to that thousand dollar
emergency fund at the very end because
you know being in sales I wanted to have
a little bit of a hills and valleys fund
in case of a real emergency mm-hmm um
cuz you've got some really really great
months and then some not-so-great months
mm-hmm so I threw a chunk of that out my
parents were a big help and and they
threw a little bit at that too for me
and then helped out in the sense that I
got to grocery shop in their
refrigerator a lot that's nice yeah
that's good okay so you've been on beans
and rice and mom and dad's refrigerators
yes there you go I was a great cook too
so it wasn't just shopping in the
refrigerator for fruits and vegetable
she would make me home-cooked meals all
the time so very nice what a great way
to support you though while you're doing
this yeah just to cheer you on so you
had a good support group around you're
very very good well what is your advice
to someone listening that's thirty years
old and single and they've got $50,000
in debt and they say gosh I wish I could
do that you obviously you're going to
tell them they can do it you did it but
how did you do it what do you say the
keys are I would say you just really
have to do it you're going to have some
tough times but sit down make a budget
and stick to it because without it you
really have no idea where your money is
going and honestly
target was killing me I would just go
and spend a ton of money and I don't
even know on what it's it just you know
you go in for bananas and you walk out
with a hundred and fifty dollars we're
stuff it's tough jumps in your buggy in
target I'll never see anything like it
it's like it's alive or something yeah
yep it does that in a lot of stores well
way to go
congratulations all right we're going to
send you a give you a copy while you're
here of Chris Hogan's number one book
retire inspired and of course that's
your next chapter now is build wealth
and not only if something happened with
you and John not only would you have a
pile of money then that you know debt
but you'd have a pile of money right so
there you go it's starting to get a
better picture all the time here so all
right very very cool well very proud of
you very good job thank you you're a
hero good job you took control of your
life
all right Joanne is from Chicago
forty-nine thousand five hundred five
hundred fifty thousand dollars paid off
in 15 months making $70,000 a year count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one I'm debt free
where to go
now I'm gonna do something a little
different here cuz I think it's I want
to hear John what are you what's your
take on all of this stuff I couldn't be
more proud of her really I don't know
how she did it that it she just started
and I just started snowballing and then
I would always compare it to a car cuz
I'm a car guy so when she started is
like oh that's uh no uh three series
goodnight and then slowly start going
down to like a focus and fiesta is a
used car range and then once you get
below my Bronco range it was a yeah it
was paid off yeah I was beautiful way to
go oh very cool
yeah and Joanne I just want to say these
past two and a half years been beautiful
oh let's go good I'm sorry
um I love you so much and I want to
spend the rest of my life with you
oh you marry me yes
oh love it we get an on-air proposal and
here comes the flowers I love it how fun
is that now if you're just looking into
your radio you didn't get to see all of
that you missed it but YouTube streamers
are all going nuts right now the people
watching on YouTube and you guys can
come back and watch it online if you
want you can just go the Dave Ramsey
show app because this is all on
television for those of you didn't know
well I mean whatever you call it online
TV but anyway so congratulations you two
Wow hi can you bring them back so I
could talk to him congratulations guys
thank you John you work your breathing
kind of hard man oh he's like I thought
you were gonna pass out there wait a
minute I was Lee hearing that microphone
he's like he's just supposed to be
watching he's did you have any idea no
no I thought it was actually going to
happen last weekend when his friend was
getting married I didn't know cholesky
wasn't that I thought is there even a
Lesley where are we going China Illinois
I don't know where this is and it didn't
happen last weekend it just happened now
oh my god congratulations you two
oh he's been where he's been working
with our production team for him for a
month
getting this lined up so very well done
well congratulations let us be the first
to congratulate you
very well done congratulations you guys
all right John
and our Joanne and her new fiance John I
love it I just said that
that's very cool oh well we've had a
couple of proposals here on the air over
the years and but it's been a I guess
it's been a couple years since we've had
one here in the lobby that's a lot of
fun very fun well the the thing that
happens for sure is when you can get on
the same page about handling money then
you do have someone that you have a lot
of shared values with you do have
someone that's easy to think about
sharing your dreams and sharing your
future with so very very cool stuff how
wonderful are they
so fun very cool and happen right see
this doesn't happen on other talk radio
shows this is the only show that does
stuff like that this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or five hundred thousand dollar
Endicott